décembre 1940 le tracé de la ligne de
démarcation séparant la france libre de
la france occupée passe par la ville de
descartes dans le sud touraine dans
cette période difficile une femme va
s'illustrer de façon exemplaire cette
femme c'est jeanne goupille les pouces
d'un vétérinaire tous les membres de
cette famille là vont participer à la
résistance jeanne est les gaullistes 1
et donc quand elle entend l'appel du 18
juin un petit déclic se fait elle se dit
c'est pas possible il faut faire quelque
chose et donc elle est un peu là le
moteur les goupilles était en zone
occupée et souvent landry groupe i comme
vétérinaire devait aller de l'autre côté
de la ligne et donc il avait un
laissez-passer et de ce fait là il a pu
faire passer des messages des tracts des
armes également et jeanne aph et à
beaucoup un rôle de passeuse avec ses
filles elle a fait passer la ligne de
démarcation à des milliers de personnes
à viet rallier juifs ou opposants pour
chasser ces passages clandestins
dureront jusqu'en 1943 dénoncé jeanne et
les siens seront arrêté torturé et
déporté presque tous reviendront alors
bien sûr après la fin de la guerre
jeanne a été reconnu juste parmi les
nations comme les autres membres de sa
famille mais lorsqu'une rue est créé
pour honorer ses actes héroïques c'est
le prénom de son mari andré qui lui est
donné